les plus loin puisque je comprends que
la suspicion ne porte pas sur mon
administration et accessoirement ma
personne mais sur d'autres qui
pourraient me succéder mais lorsqu'elle
a la meilleure manière d'être garanti
c'est que personne ne me succède jamais
mais je pense que ça si ça susciterait
beaucoup de désespoir sur un certain
nombre de banques donc il faut un
dispositif plus sérieux que celui que je
viens de vous proposer et donc le
dispositif plus sérieux que je vienne
vous proposez c'est quoi c'est que moi
je suis tout à fait d'accord pour qu'on
mette en place un dispositif qui
annuellement conduisent l'ansi laden sic
la cnil et des parlementaires désignés à
contrôler l'adéquation qu'il y as entre
les dernières recommandations d'annecy
le contenu du décret le fonctionnement
de l'application avec un souci de
transparence totale c'est pas simplement
un avis conforme de l'ansea une fois et
un rapport de la dnccg une fois je suis
prêt a fait nullement annuellement
on organise des conditions de contrôle
de l'application et de la base qui
permettrait d'éviter que cette
inquiétude de prosper monsieur le
sénateur pilée que puis-je faire de plus
peu de choses